uh we mentioned offline
because we've been talking so much about
visualization
uh grant sanderson through luwan brown
so
he's inspired millions of people with
the kind of uh exactly the kind of way
of thinking that you've been talking
about yeah i love his
work converting sort of uh
mathematical concepts into visual
uh
like uh visually representing them
exploring them in ways that uh help you
illuminate like the concepts
um
what do you think is the role of that so
he uses mostly programmatic
visualization so it's the thing i
mentioned where there's like animations
created by writing uh computer programs
um like what what do you think how
scalable is that approach but in general
what do you think about his impression i
think it's amazing i should work with
him
i i can share some of our visuals and he
can make them in that amazing way um
so part of it is storytelling but part
of it is like
it's creating the visuals and then
weaving a story with those visuals that
kind of builds like there's also i mean
there's also drama in it you start with
a small example and then you try it all
of a sudden there's a surprise yeah yeah
yeah and it really i mean it makes you
fall in love with the that's right with
the concept yeah he does talk about that
his sense is like some of the stuff
he he he doesn't feel like he's teaching
like the core curriculum which is
something you know
he sees himself as an
inspirational figure
but because i think it's too difficult
to kind of convert all of the curriculum
into those elements
and probably you don't need to i mean
you
if
people get to experience mathematical
ideas in the way that he shares them
um that will change them and it will
change the way they they think and maybe
they could go on to take some other
mathematical idea and make it that
beautiful well he does that
uh there's a
he created a library called manum
and he open sourced it and that library
is the uh people should check it out
it's
written in python
and it uses some of those same elements
like it allows you to animate equations
and animate little shapes like people
that
you know he has a very distinct style in
his videos and what that resulted in
even though from a software engineer
perspective the code he released is not
like
super well documented or perfect
but him releasing that
now there's all of these other people
educating it and the cool to me
personally the coolest thing is to see
like
people they're not you know
don't have like a million subscribers or
something is they they they have just a
few views in the video but it just seems
like
the process of them creating a video
where they teach
is like transformative to them yeah from
a student perspective it's the old
feynman thing the best way to learn is
to teach right and then him releasing
that into the wild is yeah
it shows that that impact yeah
absolutely i think just giving people
that idea that you can do that with
maths and other subjects they're
bound to be people all around who can
create more which is cool yeah i
definitely so i recommend people do like
javascript or python you can you can
build like visualizations of
most concepts in high school math you
can do a lot of kinds of visualizations
and doing that yourself
plus if you do that yourself people will
really love it people actually
people love visualizations of math yeah
because they i mean it's something in us
that loves patterns loves figuring out
difficult things and the patterns in
that are then are unexpected in some way
yeah have you ever noticed that hotels
are always filled with patterns
i was just noticing at the hotel i mean
now all of their carpets are patent
carpets and then they have patterns on
the walls
yeah so
yeah we humans love
the symmetry and patterns the breaking
of symmetry and patterns
yeah
and it's funny that we don't see
mathematics is somehow intricately
connected to that but it is
right i mean that's one of the
perspectives i love students to take is
to be a pattern seeker
in everything in in yeah certainly in
all of maths i mean you can think of all
of maths as a kind of subject of
patterns and
not just visual patterns but
you know when you think about
multiplying by five
and the fact you can
you know if you if you're multiplying 18
times five
you can instead think of 9 times 10.
that's a pattern that always works in
mathematics you can have a number and
double number and so yeah i just think
there are patterns everywhere and if
kids are thinking their role is to see
patterns and find patterns it's
really exciting
what do you think about like mit open
courseware
and the release of lectures by
universities i think it's good
i think it's good i think the
that is what started
the
mooc i did was
using that platform so you ultimately
think like the udacity models is a
little bit more effective than just a
plain two-hour lecture i think there's
definitely you can bring in good
pedagogy into online learning and i
think the idea of putting things online
so that people all over the world can
access them it's great i don't think the
initial excitement around moocs
sort of democratizing education and make
it more equal
came about because they found that the
people taking moocs tended to be the
more privileged people
so that was i think there's still
something to be found in that there's
still more to be done to
help that online learning reach those
principles but um definitely i think
it's it's a good
invention and i have an online class
that's for kids that's little free class
that gives the topic it's called how to
learn maths
um
it shows maths as this visual creative
subject and it shares mindset and some
brain science and
um
kids who take it do better in maths
class we've studied it with like
randomized controlled trials and
given it to middle school kids and other
middle school kids who don't take it but
are taught by the same teachers so their
teachers are the same and the kids who
take the online class end up
68 more engaged in their maths class and
do better at the end of the year so
that's a little six session 15 minute
class and
it changes kids maths relationships so
it is true that we can do that with some
words
that aren't you know not it's not a huge
change to the education system
you